I do a pretty good Trump impression yeah
as you all know I'm running for
president again it's going to be so
great and my motto My slogan is going to
be make America great again
excuse me
Rosie O'Donnell she's a dog
Rosie O'Donnell she is not gonna like it
but I'm not surprised are you surprised
first I'm not surprised at all she's a
dog excuse me it's so disgusting excuse
me tiny meat gang podcast I can't relate
to it at all I can relate to it at all
these are really good I'm not ticklish
at all
but if Stormy Daniels or maybe Melania
Melania is tickling me then I might
giggle a little bit I don't know
all right I'm done oh you did not bro